sup guys name is John Baron my website
well I guess there's a couple different
ones lasers John Baron com where you can
find me at and there's also another one
that I work for which Mr host sports
called mr. calm and I'm here tonight at
Holly shores our own festival with a
locally Karen we're on the red carpet
and also
you get involved with Molly shorts um
well actually I had a good friend who
was NPR last year name was Erica's
sergeants are Darian Sartain Arians or
Erica and she told me about the event
and she got me and listed last year and
that's actually where I met David who
was currently filming David ran in and
he had a short know the big event for
the wedding and we I guess disconnected
81 goes awesome it's great for meeting
new people so what is your my interview
and what what a move or quick concise
interview tell us what makes for great
interview had us a few minutes while
you're on the cart it's crazy I think
being genuine and being true to yourself
if you then you'll be able to actually
connect the person you're interviewing
and I'd really like spontaneity that
really adds the interview as well maybe
you get your typical what movie are you
here for at once you know those typical
questions but like I like offer me
questions as well to keep the interview
little perky it was there anyone that
you were totally inseminated I
interviewed that you were just like oh
my gosh we starstruck but you did it
anyway not yet but I think there is one
person it might be that might make me
first rug maybe the picture I haven't
had a chance to interview yet but it
would be a Halle Berry figure out there
Halle Berry you might intimidate me for
a sec